which of the differential equations are
separable and i encourage you to pause
this video and see which of these are
actually separable
now the way that i approach this is i
try to solve for the derivative and if
when i solve for the derivative if i get
d y
dx is equal to some function of y times
some other function of x then i say okay
this is separable because i could
rewrite this as i could divide both
sides by g of y and i get 1 over g of y
which is itself a function of y
times d y is equal to
h of x
dx you would go from this first equation
to the second equation just by dividing
both sides by g of y and multiplying
both sides by dx and then it's clear you
have a separable equation you can
integrate both sides but the key is
let's solve for the derivative and see
if we can put this in a form where we
have the product of a function of y
times the function of x
so let's do it with this first one here
so let's see if i subtract y from both
sides i'm just trying to solve for the
derivative of y with respect to x i'm
going to get
x
x times i'll write y prime is the
derivative of y with respect to x
is equal to 3 minus y
so i subtracted y from both sides let's
see if i divide both sides by x i'm
going to get the derivative of y with
respect to x is equal to
actually i'm going to write it this way
i'm going to write it 3 minus y
times 1 over x and so it's clear i'm
able to write the derivative as the
product of a function of y and a
function of x so this indeed is
separable and i could show you i can
multiply both sides by dx and i can
divide both sides by 3 minus y now and i
would get 1 over 3 minus y
d y
is equal to 1 over x
dx so clearly this one right over here
is separable now let's do the second one
and i'm going to just do the same
technique i'll do it in a slight a
different color so we don't get all of
our math all jumbled together so in this
second one
let's see if i subtract the 2x the 2y
from both sides so actually let me just
do whoops let me
do a couple of things at once i'm going
to subtract 2x from both sides
i am going to subtract 2y from both
sides so i'm going to subtract 2y from
both sides i'm going to add 1
to both sides
so
i'm going to add 1
to
both sides and then what am i going to
get if i do that this is going to be 0
this is going to be 0 this is going to
be 0. i'm going to have 2 times the
derivative of y with respect to x
is equal to
negative 2x minus two y
plus one
and now let's see i can divide
everything by two i would get the
derivative of y with respect to x is
equal to
and actually yeah i would get i'm just
going to divide by 2. so i'm going to
get negative x
minus y
and then i'm going to get
plus
one-half
so it's not obvious to me how i can
write this as a product of a function of
x and a function of y
so this one
does not feel this this one right over
here is not separable i don't know how
to
how to write this as a function of x
times a function of y so this one i'm
not gonna i'm gonna say is not separable
now this one they've already written it
for us as a function of x times a
function of y so this one is clearly
separable right over here and if you
want me to do the separating i can
rewrite this as well this is d y
d x
if i multiply both sides by d x and
divide both sides by this right over
here i would get 1 over y squared plus y
d y
is equal to x squared plus x
dx so clearly separable
all right now this last choice this is
interesting they've essentially
distributed the derivative right over
here so let's see if we were to unfactor
the derivative i'm just going to solve
for d y d x so i'm going to factor it
out
i'm going to get d y
d x
times x plus y
x plus y
is equal to x now if i were to divide
both sides by x plus y i'm going to get
d y
d x is equal to x over x plus y
and here i my algebraic toolkit of how
do i separate x and y so i can write
this as a function of x times a function
of y
not obvious to me here so this one is
not separable so only the first one and
the third one